we have had in the last 24 hours an absolutely
unhinged, unrestricted, unfettered rampaging
Donald Trump, who has threatened to obliterate
the Turkish economy. We have the tweets. Why
is Trump talking about obliterating a a country's
economy that he can't even find on a map?
Because it all relates to pulling American
troops from Syria. And I'll explain and we
will have a discussion about it. A Donald
Trump, once again has brought up this issue
of pulling troops from Syria. He's been talking
about this for some time now, and Donald Trump
made the announcement that he is pulling back
troops from the North of Syria and allowing
Turkey to do a military offensive in the area.
Now, there are even supporters of Donald Trump's
that are saying, this makes no damn sense.
This includes a Republican presidential Brown
noser, Lindsey Graham. Uh, this includes Brian
Kilmeade on Fox news. We'll get to that a
little bit later. But Donald Trump took to
Twitter and said, don't worry if Turkey does
anything I don't like, I will destroy their
economy. Nice. Right? Even crazier is that
in threatening to obliterate their economy,
Trump patted himself on the back for being
a genius and also referenced previously destroying
economies. I don't even know that I understand
what he says here. Let's take a look quote.
As I have stated strongly before and just
to reiterate, if Turkey does anything that
I, in my great and unmatched wisdom, this
is someone with a deep, deep, deep problem
consider to be off limits. I will totally
destroy and obliterate the economy of Turkey
I've done before.
They must with Europe and others, watch over
the captured ISIS fighters and families. The
U S has far done, far more than anyone could
have expected, including the capture of 100%
of the ISIS caliphate. It is time now for
others in the region, some of great wealth
to protect their own territory. The USA is
great, incredible stability evidenced by these
tweets, right? I will totally destroy and
obliterate the economy of Turkey. Also. What
is the mean I've done before? Does he mean
he's previously destroyed Turkey's economy?
Does he mean he's previously threatened to
destroy Turkey's economy? Does he mean that
he's previously destroyed other economies?
I don't know what he means, and this is not
merely just more Trump insanity. There are
not only really important policy things to
discuss with this entire Syria thing within
hours of Donald Trump doing this. Turkey has
already attacked Kurdish, uh, positions in
Northern Syria, which we'll talk about in
a little bit.
Uh, Trump originally said we're getting out
of Syria and you had rightists say that that's
good because they just like anything that
Donald Trump says you had some rightists say
it's bad because they are wanting more troops
in as many places as possible. You had some
leftists say good. Anytime Trump wants troops
out of somewhere, we should support it. But
the real analysis required more nuance we
are against as progressives, we are against
pointless counter productive, indefinite,
sometimes illegal military engagements. No
question, no argument from me in the big picture,
we want troops out of Syria. But when Trump
does it with seemingly no strategic imperative
or timing or common sense, when we should
be concerned about why it's happening, what
was the strategic reason to pull troops unilaterally
when Trump said he was going to do it? I don't
even know if it was months or a year ago at
this point in time.
We never found one. Although there were significant,
uh, sort of motive elements that we could
find that related to Russia and they related
to Turkey and they possibly related to Trump's
business dealings in Turkey could relate to
KASHO Shoji now, I mean we'll talk about that.
And now the reason for this particular pullback
is to let Turkey run an operation which Trump
is already threatening to destroy their economy
over if he doesn't like how it goes. Does
anybody else see how bipolar and ridiculous
and nonsensical this is? And I was going to
tell you at this point in the story, we will
see what the next shoe to drop is. We actually
know what it is within hours of this announcement.
Turkey struck Kurdish targets in Northern
Syria and we're going to discuss that next.
And if you're counting on Trump's stable genius
to figure out or to try to even parse this
in any way for you, uh, good luck.